depuis plus de 25 ans les gestionnaires
de garderie sont essentiellement
autonomes chacun y va de ces critères
une minorité de dirigeants de services
de garde sélectionne par exemple les
enfants selon leur confessions
religieuse pour y mettre fin le
gouvernement le goût imposera des 2024 à
toutes les garderies subventionnées qui
sont les enfants qui doivent passer en
premier selon ce qu'a appris
Radio-Canada Québec propose que les
tout-petits ayant des défis particuliers
ou issus de milieux sociaux économiques
précaires et la priorité la précarité
économique serait définie selon le
revenu familial la précarité sociale par
la sous-solarité des parents leur jeune
âge la monoparentalité l'immigration et
l'identité autochtone notamment
autrement dit un enfant issu de
l'immigration avec des parents ayant un
faible revenu aurait beaucoup de points
et passerait avant les enfants issus
d'un milieu plus aisé les gestionnaires
de garderie salut les efforts pour
améliorer l'accès aux enfants plus
vulnérables mais ils estiment que la
centralisation prévue va trop loin
je pense que notre réseau des CPE et
sont tous d'accord tous mes collègues on
est d'accord dire qu'ils étaient temps
de faire un ménage est-ce que j'ai un
colline qui est utilisé l'image par
exemple du basica pour tuer une mouche
c'est peut-être un petit peu trop
intense le ménage qui est le sont en
train de nous proposer la liste des
temps centralisée qu'on a présentement
ça fonctionne pas le président de
l'association des garderies privées du
Québec sommes le gouvernement logo de
revoir son plan de match malheureusement
avec l'orientation proposée par le
gouvernement nos familles de la classe
moyenne ils passent en dernier nous on
trouve ces inacceptable les
gestionnaires mettent en garde Québec
contre l'idée d'imposer des critères
muranus comme l'âge des enfants à
prendre en premier il s'inquiète aussi
de la disparition de certains critères
comme proximité le fait que des parents
habitent le quartier à Québec les
parties d'opposition n'ont pas tardé à
réagir on peut pas tout décider à partir
de Québec et avoir justement une
compréhension des enjeux locaux le
fameux liste là des 51 000 noms le
ministère devait la récupérer et bien la
gérer la claque avait fait son travail
inquiète dernière année puis elle avait
répondu à ce qu'elle nous disait qu'elle
voulait que chaque enfant a une place on
serait pas rendu là la nouvelle ministre
de la Famille se dit confiante de faire
les bons changements c'est important
d'avoir une politique nationale
d'admission pour que autant les parents
que les services de garde connaissent
bien les règles du jeu je pense que dans
tous les cas ça va améliorer le système
après les gestionnaires ces derniers
mois ce sera autour des parents de la
semaine prochaine de dire au ministère
de la Famille ce qu'il pense de cette
réforme majeure prévue dès 2024 ici
Julie Marceau Radio-Canada Montréal